[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
Donnerstag die vom Sport hat Norbert
Lehmann ein schön guten Abend auch von
mir und das sind die Themen von
heute lässt der Westen die Ukraine im
Stich vor seiner USA Reise fordert der
Kanzler mehr Solidarität doch der
US-Senat sagt NEIN zu Milen
helfen rote Karte für den Kriegsgegner
die russische Wahlkommission sagt der
oppositionpolitikertin darf bei der
Präsidentenwahl nicht
antreten sie trotzen den Krisen dieser
Welt und setzen gute Laune dagegen
zeusende feiern am rehein und anderswo
[Musik]
weiberfassnacht wir beginnen mit der
Ukraine die massiv unter Druck steht
präsidentelens hat sein Armeechef
abgesetzt dazuleich mehr außerdem
blockiert der US-Senat weitere Gelder
für die Ukraine der Bundeskanzler ist
auf dem Weg nach Washington vor seinem
Abflug warnte er noch mal alle
Verbündeten eindringlich vor einem
Nachlassen der Militärhilfen für die
Ukraine was es bedeuten würde wenn die
USA wirklich aussteigen würden zeigt ein
Blick auf die Zahlen seit Kriegsbeginn
hat Washington Waffen und Munition im
Wert von rund
43,9 Milliarden Euro in die Ukraine
geliefert auf Platz 2 kommt Deutschland
mit 17,1 Milliarden Euro und liegt damit
weit vor anderen wirtschaftsstarken
EU-Ländern Frank Buchwald
berichtet der Flieger wartet Olaf Scholz
auf dem Weg in die USA krisendiplomatie
für die Ukraine gleichzeitig eine klare
Botschaft an Putin das Signal nämlich
dass er nicht darauf rechnen kann dass
unsere Unterstützung nachlässt sondern
sie wird lange genug andauern und sie
wird groß genug sein eine heikle Mission
im Kongress stehen die Zeichen auf Sturm
ein 60 Milliarden Hilfspaket für die
Ukraine durchgefallen schlechte
Nachrichten auch für Europa wir sehen
dass Trump von außen hinein regiert und
versucht
der Regierung
sehr viel Steine in den Weg zu geben auf
der anderen Seite heißt es für uns
Europäer dass wir das was wir schon seit
einiger Zeit wissen nämlich dass wir
auch im Hinblick auf europäische
Sicherheit auf eigenen Füßen stehen
müssen das bedeutet mehr Geld für die in
monatelangem Dauerfeuer erschöpften
ukrainischen Streitkräfte auch aus
Deutschland ein
Milliardenbetrag das ist auch gut
angelegtes Geld denn wenn Putin die
Ukraine vereinnamt glaube ich wird er
früher oder später auch nach anderen
Ländern ausgreifen und dann wird die
Sache noch viel komplizierter noch viel
teurer und viel brutaler für uns die
Ukraine die unter russischen
Luftschlägen leidet braucht dringend
Hilfe das Veto aus Washington ein
Härtetest für die Solidarität der
Europäer was es für uns bedeutet dass
egal wie in den Vereinigten Staaten im
November gewählt wird so oder so wir in
Europa uns deutlich stärker darauf
einstellen müssen wenn wir wirklich an
der Seite der Ukraine sein wollen und
das wollen wir deutlich mehr
Unterstützung in die Hand zu nehmen so
wird der Kanzler in den nächsten Wochen
wohl eine Menge Überzeugungsarbeit
leisten müssen nicht allein in
Washington jetzt in die Ukraine wo
Präsident selenski die militärische
Führung ausgewecht hat der
Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte
valerie salusni ist von seinem Posten
entbunden worden das teilte der
Präsident am Abend in einer
Videobotschaft mit es sei an der Zeit
dass jemand anderes die Streitkräfte
anführe schon länger gab es einen
offenen Machtkampf zwischen selenski und
dem vor allem bei den Soldaten beliebten
Oberkommandierenden saluschni zum
Nachfolger sei Generaloberst Alexander
sirski ernannt worden fragen wir nach
bei Katrin Eigendorf in Kiev was
bedeutet dieser Wechsel und wofür steht
der
neue also dieser Wechsel bedeutet dass
selenski ganz klar gemacht hat dass er
der Präsident ist und hier bestimmen
will wer die Ukraine nach außen vertritt
wer über die Lage auch seine westlichen
Partner informiert der Auslöser für das
Zerwürfnis war ein Interview das salusen
dem Economist gegeben hat wo er
beschrieben hat dass es eine
patsituation zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine militärisch gebe das hat
selenski sehr
gestört dieser Machtkampf ist damit
jetzt beendet und das ist ein ziemlich
klares Signal er hat sich jetzt für
einen Mann entschieden der für
strategische militärische Erfolge steht
für die Befreiung des Ostens der Ukraine
er steht auch dafür verhindert zu haben
dass Kiev eingenommen wird von den
Russen am Anfang des Krieges er ist ein
Pragmatiker der sowohl Russland gut
kennt er hat dort die Militärakademie
besucht aber auch die NATO gut kennt und
er verspricht sich davon eben einen
Neuanfang zirski setzt vor allem auf die
Technologisierung des Krieges das hat er
immer wieder betont wir haben ihn zum
Interview getroffen und da hat er uns
das erklärt was er sich für die Zukunft
der Ukraine vorstellt mehr Technologie
mehr Zusammenarbeit mit westlichen
Partnern wichtige Information live aus
Kiev danke schön Katrin
Eigendorf für die deutsche Marine ist es
der gefährlichste satz seit Jahren sie
soll Frachtschiffe im Roten Meer vor
Angriffen der hui Milizen Schützen im
Rahmen einer eu- missission die Fregate
Hessen hat sich dazu aus wilhelmsafen
auf den Weg gemacht sie ist mit
Flugabwehrraketen ausgestattet und
spezialisiert auf seeraumkontrolle und
Geleitschutz der Einsatz vor der Küste
des Jemen muss noch formell von den EU
Außenministern und vom Bundestag
beschlossen werden Thomas
Reichard leinenl für die Fregatte Hessen
heute in Wilhelmshafen es ist einer der
gefährlichsten Einsätze der deutschen
Marine seit Jahrzehnten und ein schwerer
Abschied
beklommen sehr beklommen die Besatzung
von 250 Soldatinnen und Soldaten soll im
Roten Meer den Schiffverkehr schützen
vor den hui Milizen die Hessen kann
Angriffe mit Raketen Drohnen oder
sogenannten kamikazboten abwehren
zuletzt aber gab es Zweifel ob die
Marine auch genug Munition hat wir sind
durchhaltefähig ansonsten würde ich eine
solche Einheit und unsere Menschen dort
auch nicht nicht
hinschicken wir sehen was andere was
andere Schiffe dort verschießen wir
können das nachhalten im im Bedarfsfall
es geht um eine der wichtigsten
schiffahsrouten der Welt wegen der
Angriffe der huis wagen sich immer
weniger Schiffe durch rotes Meer und
sugeskanal nehmen stattdessen den langen
Umweg um das K der guten Hoffnung die
Strecke verlängert sich um ungefähr Z
Wochen wenn sie nach nach Europa fahren
wollen mit den asienverkehren das
verursacht natürlich erheblichste
Mehrkosten die Hessen soll die Frachter
schützen sie fährt in ein Kriegsgebiet
wo amerikanische und britische Schiffe
hui Stellungen angreifen die
amerikanische Marine ist bereits unter
Beschuss geraten sie geht davon aus dass
sie weiter unter Beschuss gerät und das
kann man glaube ich für die EU Mission
gleichermaßen annehmen nach dem
Beschluss der EU muss auch noch der
Bundestag dieser Mission zustimmen
fregat und Besatzung werden da schon im
Roten Meer
sein nach Russland da sind im März
Präsidentschaftswahlen und er wollte
Wladimir Putin eigentlich herausfordern
Boris nadjestin ein liberaler
Oppositioneller und Gegner des Kriegs in
der Ukraine aber die Wahlkommission hat
jetzt entschieden an der Wahl darf
nadtin nicht teilnehmen der Grund die
Listen mit den erforderlichen
Unterschriften von Unterstützern aus dem
ganzen Land seien nicht korrekt tin
kündigte an dagegen zu
klagenin kper in Moskau die Wiederwahl
Putins gilt als vollkommen sicher warum
lässt der nadestin trotzdem nicht
antreten ich denke einfach weil die
Unterstützung für n den drohte
unkontrollierbar groß zu werden und man
im Kremmel nicht dem Zufall überlassen
will man muss ja eins verstehen diese
Wahl ist nach unserem Verständnis keine
sondern für den Kremmel eine ganz
plantete strategische Operation die hat
als Ziel den Wahlsieg des Kandidaten
Putin mit mindestens
75% bei einer Wahlbeteiligung von 70%
Plus um dem Ganzen den Anschein einer
demokratischen Legitimation zu geben
Gegenkandidaten gibt es die sind
politisch profillos und haben Funktionen
die des Kandidaten nadestin wäre gewesen
die Kriegsgegner an die wahlohnen zu
bringen Stichwort hohe Wahlbeteiligung
die Entscheidung von heute zeigt dass
man die Gefahr einer solchen Kandidatur
in Bezug auf Lautstärke z.B im Wahlkampf
höher gewertet hat als den möglichen
strategischen Nutzen vielen Dank Amin
Körper aus
Moskau schauen wir jetzt nach Pakistan
eine Atommacht in Südasien mit starken
Nachbarn wie Indien und China heute wird
gewählt in Pakistan über
245 Millionen Menschen leben hier
überwiegend Muslime die Wirtschaft seit
Jahren am Boden aktuell rund 30%
Inflation dazu immer wieder
Naturkatastrophen fast jeder fünfte gilt
als unterernährt in der Politik zieht
das Militär immer noch die Fäden aus
Islamabad Johannes
Hano die Atommacht Pakistan steht vor
dem wirtschaftlichen Kollaps viele
Menschen haben nicht mehr genügend Geld
um sich etwas zu essen zu kaufen und
immer wieder gibt es Terroranschläge
Schuld geben die Menschen dem
politischen Establishment VI Pakistani
sind überzeugt dass nur ein Mann sie aus
der Misere führen kann wir sind im
Parteibüro im Wahlkreis des ehemaligen
pakistanischen Premierministers im ranan
in Islamabad der aber sitzt im
Gefängnis wir konkurrieren in diesen
Wahl nicht gegen unsere politischen
Gegner wir konkurrieren gegen die
Institutionen und die Polizei im ran der
religiöse Populist der die Wahlen nach
allen Umfragen wohl mit großem Vorsprung
gewonnen hätte wurde kurz vor den Wahlen
unter anderem wegen Korruption zu mehr
als 30 Gefängnis verurteilt die
Kandidaten seiner Partei PTI dürfen nur
als unabhängige Kandidaten
antreten es ist sehr schlecht was mit
der PTI passiert es wurde gemacht um
deren Wähler zu entmutigen aber die
Wähler kennen mittlerweile die Tricks
des politischen Establishments und des
Militärs große Teile der Bevölkerung
glauben dass hinter allem KS politische
Gegner und das Militär stecken das im
Hintergrund die Fäden zieht noch gibt es
keintlichesbnis aber steht jetzt schon
fest ganz egal welche Partei am Ende
gewinnen wird ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung hat den Glauben an das
politische System verloren Pakistan
steht vor enormen politischen
Herausforderungen wann die ersten
Wahlergebnisse kommen ist im Moment noch
völlig
unklar schon wieder ein Negativrekord
beim Wetter dieser Januar war weltweit
der wärmste der je gemessen wurde das
gab das europäische Institut Kopernikus
bekannt und auch die vergangenen 12
Monate waren besonders und lagen
durchgehend bei über 1,5° im Vergleich
zum vorindustriellen Zeitalter eine
schnelle Reduzierung der Treibhausgase
sei der einzige Weg die Erderwärmung und
die Folgen wie Hitzewellen Dürren und
Überschwemmungen zu stoppen Manen die
Wissenschaftler deutschland braucht
Energie möglichst erneuerbare algerien
hat reichlich davon Wirtschaftsminister
habbeck will bei seinem zweitägigen
Besuch die Zusammenarbeit stärken
algerien ist das flächenmäßig größte
Land Afrikas gut sechsm größer als
Deutschland wichtiges Projekt dort
grüner Wasserstoff der entsteht wenn man
Wasser spaltet in Sauerstoff und
Wasserstoff und grün ist er wenn der für
die Spaltung notwendige Strom etwa aus
Solarenergie kommt Sonne die gibt's in
Algerien reichlich Anne Arend Lachat in
der Wüste Algeriens hunderttausende
Solarmodule reihen sich aneinander und
es sollen noch viel mehr werden um den
Energie Wandel
voranzutreiben die fossilen Energien die
derzeit ja hauptsächlich exportiert
werden sollen durch erneuerbare Energien
ersetzt werden so können wir unsere
Exportmöglichkeiten
erweitern denn mit Hilfe von
Sonnenenergie wird der nachgefragte
grüne Wasserstoff hergestellt über einen
Pipeline corridor der Tunesien Italien
und Österreich passiert soll der
Energieträger künftig nach
Süddeutschland gelangen zum Ausbau von
Infrastruktur und Produktion wurde heute
eine gemeinsame Wasserstoff Taskforce
gegründet überall in Deutschland werden
neue Industrieanlagen aufgebaut die
statt Gas Wasserstoff verbrauchen wollen
algerien hat dafür großartige Potenziale
algerien ist zudem als wichtiger Akteur
in der arabischen Region von
geopolitischem Interesse viel
Aufmerksamkeit für ein Land dessen
Regierung die Pressefreiheit einschränkt
und politische Gegner
verfolgt der Besuch trägt auch dazu bei
dass sich das algerische Regime
bestätigt fühlt in seinem Bestreben das
Land immer weiter in eine Diktatur zu
führen keineswegs würde die
Menschenrechtslage ignoriert heißt es
dazu aus dem deutschen Ministerium doch
im Vordergrund stand heute das Werben um
Algerien als gefragter Energiepartner
Europas mit Wärme und Vernunft aufklären
das war das KO von Alfred groser er half
den deutschen die Franzosen zu verstehen
und umgekehrt im Alter von 99 Jahren ist
der Publizist gestorben der Name Alfred
Grosser sei für immer verbunden mit der
deutsch-französischen Aussöhnung so
Bundespräsident Steinmeier der in
Frankfurt geborene grosser war in den
30er Jahren mit seiner Familie vor den
Nazis nach Frankreich geflohen der
Politologe warb stets für einen
Ausgleich zwischen den
Völkern auf Island ist wieder ein Vulkan
ausgebrochen aus einer 3 km langen
Erdspalte schießen leuchtende
Lavafontänen in den Himmel wie beim
letzten Ausbruch vor knapp einem Monat
ist das Gebiet um die Stadt grinderwig
betroffen im Südwesten des Landes nahe
der Touristenattraktion Blaue Lagune
schob sich ein Lavastrom über eine
Straße eine unmittelbare Gefahr bestehe
aber
nicht das war heute nur was für
hartgesottene Karnevals und
nachtsfreunde das Wetter zum auftagt des
stransten Karnevals miserabel die
Stimmung dennoch prächtig Weiberfasnacht
20124 Thomas münten war dabei 2
1 die Stimmung groß zum Wetter würde der
kölsche sagen fies trotzdem kamen
ztausende heute morgen schon in aller
Frühe in die Stadt Karneval trotz so
vieler Krisen in der Welt jetzt erst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rechtit man dazwischen Luft hat und
wieder atmen kann dass man feiern kann
mit Leuten die das gleiche machen wir
haben trotzdem Bock wir werden trotzdem
feiern und während rund um den Dom
ausgelassen gefeiert wurde stieg auch
die Stimmung in den Kneipen überall bis
zum Abend aber blieb es überwiegend
friedlich in der
Stadt fast nachtsauftagt im Dauerregen
auch in Mainz und auch hier trotz
widriger Umstände beste Laune bei den
Feiernden
Weibern trotz Regen einfach super wir
feiern wir machen das Beste draus
h riesenstimmung trotz Regens auch zum
karnevalsauftagt in Düsseldorf hier
stürmten die Möhnen um Punkt 11: Uhr das
Rathaus und holten sich den
Stadtschlüssel egal ob am Rhein oder am
Main es wird ein feuchtes
fastnachtswochenende in diesem Jahr von
innen und leider wahrscheinlich auch
vieler Orts wettertechnisch von
außen
hallo
ja genau und feucht passt auch zum DFB
Pokal Norbert das Viertelfinale fiel im
warsten wortsin ins Wasser ja wir beide
hatten es ja gestern Abend schon
befürchtet dass das nichts wird mit
sebrücken gegen Gladbach bei dem
Dauerregen Spielabsage des DFB aber erst
kurz vor Anstoß wegen Unbespielbarkeit
des
Platzes 16 000 Zuschauer im Ludwigspark
erleben hautnass mit warum es keine gute
Idee war bei der Sanierung des
städtischen Stadions vor einigen Jahren
auf ein Entwässerungssystem für
Regenwasser zu verzichten man hat dann
schon mal keinen Platz zum spielen wir
fühlen mit den Fans den Vereinen und wir
können uns auch nur entschuldigen für
die Unannehmlichkeiten denn der Rasen
war auch aus unserer Sicht in einer
inakzeptablen Form den Bau der
notwendigen Entwässerungsanlage hat die
Stadt kürzlich beschlossen für den
Nachholtermin der Begegnung ist das zu
spät man muss auf einen regenfreien Tag
in sabrücken hoffen oder einen anderen
Spielplatz
finden Präsident Alexander jefferin wird
überraschend 2027 nun doch nicht für
eine weitere Amtszeit kandidieren zuvor
hatte ihm der UEF Kongress in Paris
durch eine umstrittene Statutenänderung
diese Möglichkeit aber eröffnet der
Verband so jefferin wörtlich brauche
frisches Blut im Anschluss an den UEFA
Kongress gab es heute die Auslosung der
nations League und da trifft Deutschland
in der A-Liga auf die Niederlande Ungarn
und bosnienhzegwiina gespielt wird im
zweiten Halbjahr 2024 an sechs
Spieltagen mit hin und Rückspiel die
vier besten Nationen sind auch für die
WM 2026
qualifiziert bei der schwimmwm in DOA
hat das deutsche Team bei den
freiwasserwettbewerben komplett
enttäuscht nachdem zunächst die
Doppelweltmeister Leonie Beck und
Florian welbrock in den Einzel keine
Chance auf eine Medaille hatten
schwammen heute die mixstaffel ohne
Wellbrock knapp an Protest vorbei und
wurde Vierte hinter Australien Italien
und
Ungarn ja vielleicht klappt's ja bei den
Wettbewerben in eckenbesser ab Sonntag
danke schön das Wetter ist nicht gerade
fassnachtsfreundlich der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen im Westen und Südwesten
Deutschlands mehr gleich von östen terli
das heute journal um 22:30 Uhr mit
Christian siers wir sagen danke und
tschüss bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja rekordwarm ist
der Zeit der Nordatlantik und von dort
aus kommt die feuchte und teils auch
Wärme mit sie sehen es hier von der
Biskaya kommt die Feuchtigkeit auch die
milde Luft und vor allem von Süden her
wird diese Wärme dann angezapft der
Regen der setzt sich nach nach Norden
durch und verdrängt tatsächlich die
Kaltluft in der Nacht also verbreitet
Regen ja und teilweise ergiebig und der
Regen wandert nach Nordosten hin im
Norden ist sogar noch Schnee dabei und
hier in diesem Bereich gibt es Glätte
bei Temperaturen von ull bis -2° also
hier kann es gefährlich glatt werden
örtlich zumindest noch 10° im Südwesten
und diese Wärme die drängt allmählich
nach Nordosten morgen dann viel Regen
erst einmal am Vormittag auch im
Südwesten dann lockert das von Südwesten
auf im Norden gibt's Regen und der
Schnee der verabschiedet sich hier ganz
im Norden Deutschlands bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 2° ganz im Norden also
wenn sich diese Kälte hier durchsetzen
würde wäre es winterlich aber die Luft
kommt von Südwesten her 17 teils 15°
dort ja und die nächsten Tage bleiben
überwiegend wechselhaft immer wieder
etwas Regen bis 18° am Samstag mit
föhnunterstützung schönen Abend